[Musique]
et rappelle qu'on est à l'égal destin on
a eu de bons moments
tu te rappelles auj
j'ai du boulot pour toi
[Musique]
bouge toi
on aurait dit un genre de traitement ils
m'ont dit que c'était la suivante et
peuvent pas nous laisser filer la seule
chose à faire maintenant c'est foutent
le camp et trouve à un endroit où on se
fait tout petit pourra faire tout ce que
tu voudras
tu me dégoûtes
soit réglo avec moi et je serai réglo
avec toi
[Musique]
des marques [ __ ] c'était quoi ça c'est
ma soeur tiffany je vais veiller sur
elle maintenant je m'entraîne dans nos
histoires qui a pensé à ça
c'est vos filles
osez qui en fait je suis un gars qui a
fait son possible pour sortir deux
gamines de leur mère de dieu jusque ce
gars comprennent le message hockey
[Musique]
sur mon but
mais je suis pas là elles ont besoin de
bonnes âmes qui veille sur elle
se pose pas non promis